non caperi mai mai mai
mai le cere di sicurezza Oh no come
facciamo Ce n'è un'altra Oh no ma che
far
unaltro troppo forte fa dichiaro forte
te dobbiamo scappare dalla prigione
dobbiamo anche recuperare il mio libro
La città stregata che è custodito in una
stanza di massima sicurezza dentro a una
teca dobbiamo riprender celo deve essere
nostro Sì come facciamo senza e se voi
non ce l'avete ancora è ora disponibile
online in libreria cosa state aspettando
andate subito a prenderlo ma l'unico
problema è che per uscire da questa
prigione dobbiamo distrarre i
poliziotti Io sono il poliziotto Manuele
e Ho già bevuto 15 caffè 16 17 perché
devo fare la guardia ai carcerati 24 ore
su 24 7 giorni su 7 non riusciranno mai
a
scappare Io sono il poliziotto Marzio e
controllo le telecamere di sicurezza e
sono un poliziotto molto attento anche
se ogni tanto mi lascio distrarre da
queste Delizie e se qualcuno Prova a
rubare i miei dolcetti sa già la fine
che lo aspetta e solo se sicuro che
nessuno riuscirà a sfuggire al mio
occhio attento Jimny tutto a posto mi
ricevi Sì sì ci sono Sono qui nella
stanza di massima sicurezza che sto
controllando gli oggetti
preziosi Io sono Ginny e sono una
poliziotta super attenta nessun ladro si
potrà avvicinare agli oggetti preziosi
che controllo io sono Anita e sono
finita in prigione Perché io porto
sempre il mio nuovo libro con me la
città stregata e un giorno sono entrata
in libreria avevo il mio libro in borsa
e hanno pensato che che lo avessi rubato
lì dalla libreria ma in realtà era
semplicemente il mio libro che porto
sempre con me e quindi sono finita in
prigione Io sono Alice sono finita qua
in prigione Perché c'è stato un
malinteso Eh sono entrata in gioielleria
e ho visto quella meravigliosa collana
di Tiffany da 50 carati
e Per sbaglio l'ho messa nella tasca e
sono uscita dal negozio e hanno pensato
che io la volessi
rubare Ma io ovviamente l'avevo solo
dimenticata in tasca ovvio Io mi chiamo
Nicola e faccio il bidello Mannaggia a
tutti quei dannati bambini che mettono
tutte le gomme da masticare sotto i
banchi Vabbè amo il mio lavoro e sono
stato arrestato per sbaglio perché non
so
chi Cioè
io
ha scambiato lo secchio dell'acqua con
quello della benzina e ha preso fuoco
tutto Sono
[Musica]
innocente ragazzi Dobbiamo escogitare un
piano per scappare dalla prigione e
dobbiamo anche riprendere il mio libro
le guardie non se lo meritano Sì hai
ragione ma come facciamo le guardie sono
sempre qui e quello lì è un malato di
caffè non dorme mai idea potremo
rubargli il caffè lui che ne beve così
tanto così si addormenterà subito e noi
potremmo rubargli le chiavi scappare e
così avere anche il libro di Anita Sì
hai
ragione
35 35 in
caffè Sì mi sento bene mi sento bene
Sono attento sono attento sono attento
sono attento Sì sono attento Non
scapperà nessuno farò la guardia 24 ore
su 24 7 giorni su 7 a questi
detenuti non capete mai mai mai mai mai
dal miglior poliziotto della storia Ah
che fastidioso questo poliziotto Ma
perché non sta zitto e pure
stonato
Ah mi serve il 36o
caffè Ehi
ma no Non ce n'è più non c'è più caffè
come faccio Devo andare a rifarlo ma voi
state buoni e zitti Sen No faccio
scattare l'allarme
presto adesso che se n'è andato troviamo
un piano per distrarlo Sì prepariamo una
trappola potremo usare il mio pulsante
sparapan che dite Ottima idea
[Musica]
lamelo Ecco EC facciamo finta di
niente ecco qui l'ultimo caffè questo è
l'ultimo caffè Ho finito le scorte ma
sicuramente mi basterà devo solo
B Cosè stato sono stato io forse tutto
questo caffè mi sta facendo mal di
pancia devo andare devo
andare perfetto il piano funzion
bravissimi Ma ora come facciamo a
prendergli il caffè io ho
un'idea
geneale
dai dai più a sinistra più a destra a
destra ci sto provando tira su tiralo
su Eccolo
eccolo tutto a posto senza sbarra
potevamo uscire
Oh ma vabbè dai Gi fa niente Vabbè dai
forza
nascondiamo Oh oh oh ora va molto meglio
eh caffè Ci vuole il
caffè Dov'è il mio caffè era qui
l'ultimo caffè No io senza caffè io
senza caffè ti
addormento
Sen ora non ci resta che ri le
chiavi le chiavi da Prendile Ok ci
provo Ehi ciao sono l'emoji di Anita e
ho un gioco per te Prova a lasciare mi
piace entro 5 secondi 5 4 3 2 1 tempo
scaduto ci sei riuscita a proposito di
creature Lo sapevi che nel mio nuovo
libro La città stregata c'è una
trasformazione in lupo mannaro e un
mistero da risolvere assieme prendila
anche tu e indagherà con noi per
risolvere il mistero con noi
investigatori del mistero Se non ce
l'hai ancora lo trovi ora on e in
libreria e se vuoi mandami una foto su
Instagram con il libro e ti
saluterò
Siamo siamo liberi siamo liberi Adesso
però dobbiamo andare a recuperare il
libro
Ah le camere di sicurezza Oh no come
facciamo Ce n'è un'altra Oh no come
facciamo Non dobbiamo farci scoprire se
i poliziotti dovessero vederci dalle
camere di sicurezza ci risb mattere per
un cella Sì Dobbiamo inventarci qualcosa
per cercare di non farci
scoprire Andiamo nella stanza delle
videocamere e spegniamo tutte così non
ci troveranno Sì ok Buona idea andiamo
subito a cercare la stanza di controllo
[Applauso]
via
Oh mio bel donuts Quanto sei bello tutto
farcito con la tua crema al cioccolato
non vedo l'ora di
[Musica]
mangiarti un giorno penso che mi sposerò
con un donuts c'è il poliziotto che sta
guardando le camere di sicurezza cosa
facciamo Accidenti dobbiamo trovare un
modo per distrarlo Se solo sapessimo il
suo punto debole
adesso ti
[Musica]
roro
buonissimo m Forse ho capito qual è il
suo punto debole Ho un
[Musica]
piano ultimo morso però è già
finito quanto pagherei per
aerne
Oh mio
donuts un toilet volante tutto per me me
le sta scendendo pure la
[Musica]
Boba il piano di Anita ha funzionato
Questa è la sala di controllo dobbiamo
cercare di disattivare le telecamere
senò Scoprono che siamo scappati Sì
forza
andiamo allora c'è una cosa molto
semplice da fare Sì troviamo la spina e
stacchiamo tutto No no no se stacchiamo
la spina suonerà l'allarme e ci
scopriranno ora dobbiamo trovare
qualcosa Sì Cer segui me Cerca Ok fai
fare qualcosa anche a me Però allora EC
Cosa hai trovato cosa hai
trovato il cavo aspetta oh sono tre sono
tre eh Fai fare a me sono un esperto di
queste cose Allora bisogna tagliare il
cavo azzurro Sì perché l'azzurro perché
l'azzurro è mi piace l'azzurro è il
colore del cielo sicuramente Libertà Eh
no allora
aspetta il verde il verde Sì sì il verde
sicuramente perché è verde È speranza e
quindi speriamo di riuscire Ecco no lo
so lo so Secondo me è il marrone il
marrone Vai tagli il marrone Ma siamo
sicuri io scossa non ne voglio prendere
eh Te lo sto già dicendo Ecco dove sono
le forbici forse Aspetta ce ne ho io
allora taglio il
[Musica]
marrone elettrizzante dai uno del
marrone fai
tu Ok ragazzi l'ho sistemato quel
poliziotto voi siete riusciti a
disattivare le
camere
Oh era quello giusto
Sì ho fatto malissimo stai bene no Come
mi chiamo riusciti o no Sì Elita e non
si è nemmeno attivato l'allarme Perfetto
allora non ci resta che recuperare il
libro andiamo andiamo Uh Che mal di
testa se qualcuno si avvicina se la
prenderà con il mio martello la città
stregata è troppo prezioso mi è stato
affidato E lo devo proteggere porterò a
termine questo
lavoro
Wow È
bellissimo quanto lo vorrei avere nelle
mie mani ma non mi devo
rre Oh no Lei è la poliziotta più forte
non ha nessun punto debole non è
possibile hanno tutti un punto debole
aspettate io quando sono da solo mentre
pulisco la scuola Ho inventato una nuova
tecnica di danza La chiamo kungu danza
unisco il ballo al kungu così la posso
distrarre e e la metto a tappeto
Capito Ok se pensi che possa funzionare
Ci posso provare
Ok allora sei la nostra unica arma
adesso mi raccomando metti la KO come
hai detto ci provo ok forza Vai vai
Ehi tu ora assaggerai il Conf fundanza
se tuo peggior nemico Vieni qua
affrontami
Vai Ahia
aspetta troppo forte chiaro
[Musica]
forte Tanto sono forte lo stesso
ah Adesso è il momento della mia mossa
segreta ti ho preso gli occhiali no ASA
Dove sono Dove sei tu antipatico Ah
bravissimo Wow Adesso possiamo prendere
libro quella collana di poni Sì vabbè
andiamo pranto dove sono gli occhiali
Non li trovo
uh
wow Eccolo qua il mio libro La città
stregata che ora è disponibile onl in
libreria se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo ed ecco un messaggio
segreto per voi che potrete tradurre con
l'alfabeto segreto che c'è all'interno
del libro e noi là che abbiamo
V Ciao ragazzi
[Musica]
ciao